bueno oficialmente han cerrado los
centros de votación los colegios
electorales pero las personas que
todavía están al interior de estos
centros de votación pueden ejercer su
derecho al voto en este centro de
votación donde en este momento me
encuentro en la zona 9 de ciudad de
Guatemala hace muy pocos minutos vino el
presidente de la república Alejandro
yamatei a ejercer su voto muy al final
de la jornada y muy por el contrario de
Como lo hicieron los otros candidatos
los candidatos que están aspirando a la
presidencia en esta contienda a temprana
hora recién abrieron abrieron los
colegios electorales sur y ríos emitió
su voto y después Sandra Torres
tenemos registro que aquí en ciudad
Guatemala los comicios han transcurrido
tranquilamente a excepción de una
denuncia que hizo la candidata Sandra
Torres de que su hermano a su hermano Le
violentaron el carro pero sí en la
Guatemala rural en la Guatemala de las
regiones ha habido disturbios y
enfrentamientos entre fuerza pública y
población civil esto por el denominado a
carro de votos o traslado de votos
personas foráneas que estarían llegando
a los municipios a votar por candidatos
presuntamente asociados hacia la
corrupción también han denunciado compra
de votos en el balance de la policía del
ministerio público se han presentado más
de 200 irregularidades se han aprendido
más de 30 personas Aunque la policía
habla de cerca de 100 y también se han
intimidado a los medios de comunicación
en ciertos centros de votación por
cuenta de las autoridades pues Andrés
veremos cómo afectan estas
irregularidades a los resultados que
Precisamente es lo que le pregunto ahora
cuándo los iremos conociendo
Bueno A partir de ahora los cerca de
3.500 centros de votación tienen una
misión y es cada mesa de votación debe
emitir una acta de su mesa
correspondiente para enviar la
posteriormente al centro de cómputo
donde más tarde estaremos informando
este en el hotel Gran titical futura de
ciudad de Guatemala el tribunal supremo
electoral ha dicho que entonces a partir
de las 9:30 horas de la noche hora local
Se empezarán a cargar toda la
información al sistema y muy
probablemente minutos Después tendremos
una tendencia una proyección de cuáles
serán esos candidatos a la presidencia
que podrán llegar a pasar a segunda
vuelta la presidenta magistrada del
tribunal supremo electoral sobre la
pregunta de Cuándo se conocerán los
resultados finales había dicho que estos
podrían llegar a conocerse ser solo
hasta cinco u ocho días después es decir
hasta el 30 de junio o hasta el 3 de
julio Pero otros funcionarios de juntas
departamentales pues han dicho que
podrían llegar a conocerse este mismo
martes y es que la razón de cuán
dilatados son estos comicios o el conteo
de estos comicios tiene relación con la
cantidad de papeletas por contar porque
Recuerden que hoy no solamente se está
escogiendo presidente en Guatemala sino
también alcaldes diputados al congreso y
diputados al parlamento centroamericano